mon métier c'est de sauver le plus
d'argent possible
c'est ce que j'aime c'est sauver l'art
parce que le monde considérait cette
fois c'est important que c'est le rendre
plus heureux possible en sachant tout
les avantages que nous apporte
[Musique]
m'appelle jean lamontagne je suis un
consultant normes aurait futur
[Musique]
gta louveteaux et ensuite scout c'est ça
qu'ils m'ont redonné la flamme lors que
je me suis dit il faut améliorer la
qualité de la mam et l'urbain
c'est à brûlon nullement d'un parce que
tout le monde pensait qu'ils mourraient
en septembre l'a perdu au moins 50% de
son système racinaire dans des travaux
d'excavation parce qu'ils ont celui qui
démolissent le monastère et on a suivi
la rolls du début s'est fait plus de dix
ans de jose pour second est extrêmement
fiers de conserver un regard qui
démontre au monde pour des traitements
possibles pour continuer à protéger des
arbres qui ont été endommagés l'exemple
et l'eau
[Musique]
car des stars mais ils montent à 30 m
d'euros il magnifie les 40 ans de l'or
mais vraiment un tannage extraordinaire
qui en retombant est vraiment
particulier puis on pas en forme de
parasols donc il est très peu branchu
dans le beau cahier plus âgé il devient
les primes énormes sont des rares arbres
qui vont monter à 30 mètres facilement
d'auteur et peut-être pratiquement 40
mètres de large qui fait son travail
façon d'épuration de l'air effet sa
croisade il absorbe les poussins ils
donnent l'exigent a donc fait tout son
travail et 150 ans
le gros problème de l'ordre c'est si on
ne leur soit importe il m'a
automatiquement causés par la maladie
hollandaise de l'ordre d'un champignon
pénètre dans les vaisseaux hev
posée par un petit insecte qui paie
cloud pour déposer ses oeufs un à deux
mètres de diamètre s'il se fait piquer
par un squale it peut mourir l'un n'est
pas de traitements possibles par contre
le vaccin qu'on peut donner à l'arbre a
vaincu la maladie
[Musique]
mais c'est quand même très triste de
voir comment que peu d'intérêt pour les
arbres de grande qualité puis pourtant
la santé publique arrête pas de le dire
et de plus en plus l'arbre est un
instrument salut pour notre propre
condition il s'agit de faire comprendre
à la population
il s'agit de démontrer l'importance de
conserver son arme en milieu urbain mais
c'est pas facile
[Musique]
on